und uns zugeschaltet aus erfurt ist
jetzt katrin göring eckardt die
fraktionsvorsitzende der grünen im
bundestag frau göring-eckardt wir haben
es gehört die kanzlerin befürchtet eine
gesellschaftliche debatte sozusagen
geimpfte gegen nicht geimpfte fürchten
sie die auch und wie könnte man die
lösen
wer was wir in den letzten monaten
erlebt haben ist ja immer wieder und an
vielen stellen können wir sehr froh sein
und das kann uns hoffentlich auch in den
nächsten wochen tragen aber ich glaube
dass die kanzlerin gesagt hat das
betrifft natürlich vor allen dingen auch
die politik der bundesregierung weil das
erste ist es wurde gestern wieder nichts
beschlossen und wir hätten wirklich
einen schritt weiter sein können dabei
menschen ihre grundrechte zurückzugeben
wenn kein grund mehr dafür besteht dass
sie aufgehoben worden sind wie in der
vergangenheit und gleichzeitig ist
natürlich die frage wie schaffen wir es
dass möglichst viele menschen geimpft
werden wie viele impfkampagnen gibt es
auch dort wo menschen nicht sich
automatisch selbst informieren momentane
situation wir haben mehr in
anführungszeichen billige als impfstoff
da ist aber sie müssen natürlich dafür
sorgen dass in allen sprachen in allen
stadtteilen dafür geworben wird das
geimpft wird und dann das große thema
was ist mit den kindern und jugendlichen
und das ist ein echtes versäumnis denn
die werden nicht so schnell lebenswerten
können sogar kleine kinder noch sehr
sehr steht und deswegen ist da die frage
wie haben wir eigentlich die familien
für die zukunft im blick und da finde
ich hat die bundesregierung und haben
diejenigen die da verantwortung tragen
auch in den vergangenen wochen und
monaten wieder nicht dafür gesorgt dass
wenigstens im impfstoff da ist der auch
für kinder geeignet
das waren jetzt viele themen die sie
angesprochen haben ich möchte trotzdem
noch mal darauf zurückkommen die debatte
wird kommen ich bin geimpft der nächste
ist nicht geimpft ich da was der nächste
darf es nicht wie kann man das lösen
immer ganz auf der einen seite natürlich
lösen indem man wirklich genügend es
überall zur verfügung steht wo menschen
die die imst sind ihre rechte
zurückbekommen das ist eine der
möglichkeiten die wir tatsächlich haben
und die wir auch in der vergangenheit
schon hätten haben können
das zweite thema ich bleib noch mal bei
den kindern und bei
jugendlichen die frage wann steht
eigentlich ein impfstoff für jugendliche
zur verfügung also für die zwölf- bis
16-jährigen das ist die eine frage
biontech hat da studien gemacht aber es
ist wie sonst eben häufig auch bei
medikamenten das für kinder keine
eigenen da sind und beim impfstoff ist
es eben jetzt so dass die konsequenz ist
sie sind auch nicht zugelassen für
kinder und deswegen ist das glaube ich
der druck der unbedingt gemacht werden
muss dass das
bundesforschungsministerium dass die
bundesregierung druck macht dass der
impfstoff für kinder bald kommt sonst
haben wir die situation dass auf der
einen seite ältere den ich das von
herzen gönnen
im restaurant sitzen oder in urlaub
fahren können auf der anderen seite die
familie noch mal außen vor sind die in
dieser partie nie wirklich mit
homeschooling und all dem was da dran
hängen wirklich schon genug zuzusetzen
hatten
ist das nicht ein bisschen naiv ich
meine wir haben ja ich sage mal ungefähr
ein jahr auf den jetzigen impfstoff
gewartet ein kinder eben stoff gut der
könnte jetzt ein bisschen schneller
komma wäre trotzdem nicht bis zum sommer
bis zum herz da sein das braucht ja auch
seine zeit
es ist immer so ein bisschen hätte
fahrradkette das ist in der tat so man
fragt sich warum ist nicht von anfang an
auch daran geforscht worden warum hat
die bundesregierung keine unterstützung
geleistet das ist richtig wir werden
möglicherweise eine biontech impfstoff
haben in einigen wochen wenigen monaten
der für die zwölf- bis 15-jährigen zur
verfügung steht das ist schon man weiter
für schritt ich halte es nicht so naiv
sondern ich glaube das ist die frage wie
man das hinbekommt dass nicht die
familien wieder die gleichen sinn eine
sehr zentrale ist und das würde dann
eben heißen wenn immer noch kein
impfstoff dann zumindest dafür zu sorgen
dass einfach täglich getestet wird
sowohl an den schulen als auch dort wo
man ihn gegebenenfalls seine zeit oder
seine freizeit mit kinder unter mir
verbringen will und dazu gehört eben
auch dass möglichst viele von den
anderen auch tatsächlich geimpft sind
deswegen habe ich das vorhin gesagt mit
der information weil manche wird es ja
geben die sagen da sind schon so viele
sind jetzt brauche ich das nicht mehr
und das sind eben die kinder die übrig
sind die gar nicht geimpft werden können
und deswegen ist eine impfkampagne
in allen milieus in allen bereichen sehr
sehr wichtig damit wir auf diese 80 90
prozent kommen damit die kinder eben mit
geschützt sind durch diese so genannte
herdenimmunität also auch mehr impfstoff
in sozialer brennpunkte auch mehr
information erst mal dort also eine
impfstoff der auch dort mussten ja
hausärzte und hausärztinnen da sage ich
glaube dass die wirklich der fokus auf
die betriebsärzte auch noch mal ein ganz
wichtiger punkt ist aber auch menschen
die in prekären jobs arbeiten müssen die
möglichkeit haben und die information
haben sich jetzt sehr sehr schnell
hinten zu können kommen wir zur
priorisierung markus söder möchte die am
liebsten besser heute als morgen soll
das gesagt auflösen was sagen sie dazu
da geht es ja auch zum also um eltern es
geht um lehrerinnen und lehrer und ich
finde dass dort wo lehrerinnen und
lehrer schon in der prioritäten gruppe
drin sind ist das gut ist das richtig
ich glaube dass wir ein totales kittel
anstellen wenn wir jetzt das noch mal
vollkommen verändern
deswegen geht es um schnelligkeit und
deswegen geht es darum überall mit allen
potenzialen zu impfen
bei der imm priorität geht es vor allen
dingen abgerungen dass das was viele die
gut informiert sind jetzt schon machen
nämlich beim hausarzt bei der hausarzt
anzurufen und zu sagen bevor was übrig
ist und weggeworfen wird dann rufen sie
mich bitte an das muss eben für alle
passieren und ich glaube das ist ja der
pragmatische besser schneller beschritt
wenn wir jetzt dann dazu kommen rechte
für geimpfte zurückzugeben grundrechte
glauben sie dass das dann auch meinen
bundestag besprochen werden muss
debattiert werden muss oder kann das
anders formloser über die bühne gehen
naja formlos nicht das ist ja eine
verordnung die ist ja nicht bloß und die
wird dann auch im deutschen bundestag
beschlossen werden das kann auch
natürlich sehr schnell gehen das ist so
im neuen infektionsschutzgesetz und ich
glaube dass diese debatte dort auch gut
aufgehoben ist warum
erstens weil sie dann den die
entsprechende verbindlichkeit hat und
zweitens weil die öffentliche debatte
natürlich immer auch hilft um klar zu
machen was jetzt gilt und worum es jetzt
geht wir erleben das übrigens jetzt
schon
dem infektionsschutzgesetz und
beispielsweise der home office pflicht
die wird in vielen öffentlichen
verwaltungen sich verbindlicher sehr
viel klarer angenommen und daneben auch
in betrieben als mit einer verordnung
zum gesetz ist und es ist klar das gilt
überall und überall gleich machen katrin
göring eckardt war das ganz herzlichen
dank
ich bedanke mich auch